[Musica]
se qualcuno vi chiedesse Come vi sentite
nella vostra casa che cosa rispondereste
personalmente risponderei che sto bene
in ogni ambiente della mia casa eccetto
che in uno un luogo dove prevarica il
disordine più totale è il regno di mio
figlio la sua camera da letto quando
trovo il coraggio di entrare e varcare
la soglia ovviamente Trovo la porta
sempre chiusa mi devo prima preparare a
contenere le mie reazioni nel vedere
quel cocktail di oggetti calzini
abbigliamento e Devices technologic
tecnologici pazzesco quando vi entro
Ovviamente non sto bene anzi per dirla
parole gentili mi innervosisco Ma la
cosa incredibile è che lui nella sua
stanza Sta benissimo quel luogo
evidentemente lo fa sentire come lui
vuole sentirsi e soddisfa quelli che
sono i suoi bisogni più
profondi Questo è un semplice Esempio di
come uno stesso luogo possa generare
sensazioni reazioni completamente
diverse a seconda di chi lo
viva trascorriamo più del 90% del nostro
tempo in luoghi chiusi che effetto hanno
su di noi e da cosa dipende la capacità
di un luogo di farci stare profondamente
bene solo da ciò che
vediamo Queste sono alcune delle domande
che iniziai a pormi nel 2010 che mi
portarono ad esplorare un nuovo mondo
dell'abitare un mondo Grazie al quale
possiamo dare vita in modo semplice
naturale soprattutto non convenzionale
ad ambienti positivi per noi ma cosa
significa ambienti positivi per noi
scopriamolo insieme a tutti noi Sara
capitato almeno una volta nella vita di
vedere dal vivo o su una rivista o sul
web una casa che abbiamo definito
meravigliosa di essa Ci avranno colpito
i colori i materiali l'atmosfera la
location soffermiamoci un momento su
questo oggettivo meraviglioso arriva
ovviamente dalla parola meraviglia
in questo contesto la parola meraviglia
assume un significato molto più ampio
del semplice appagamento estetico che
cosa intendo vi inviterò tra qualche
secondo a chiudere gli occhi e tornare
con la memoria e con il cuore ad un
luogo nel quale vi siete sentiti
profondamente connessi con voi stessi e
con
l'ambiente un panorama sconfinato dalla
cima di una montagna un tramonto
infuocato sul mare o un'infinita
Stellata della quale per qualche
incredibile ragione sentivate di essere
parte bene Ora vi invito a chiudere gli
occhi lo facciamo
insieme e a tornare esattamente in quel
luogo cominciamo a ricostruirne intorno
a noi i colori i
suoni i
profumi
e prestiamo attenzione al battito del
nostro cuore al nostro respiro
all'espressione del nostro
volto Godiamoci questo
momento bene facciamo un bel respiro e
riapriamo gli
occhi come ci siamo sentiti in questa
manciata di secondi pensiamo quanto
potrebbe essere è bello abitare la
meraviglia vivere in luoghi capaci di
farci provare in modo forte e
continuativo emozioni così belle come
questa quella della
meraviglia ho scelto di farvi fare
questa esperienza per un motivo per
darvi la misura in tempo reale
dell'effetto di un'emozione positiva
generata da un luogo sul nostro corpo
una ricerca condotta dal nor Bay
Hospital con l'università di Berkley
entrambi in California ha confermato che
la meraviglia ha effetti importantissimi
in termini di riduzione dello stress
dell'ansia e perfino del dolore insomma
la meraviglia sembra avere effetti
davvero sorprendenti Ma la cosa
interessante è che questi effetti
potrebbero arrivare anche da altre
emozioni di cui i nostri luoghi come la
nostra casa potrebbero essere naturali
attivatori
emozioni
abitare meraviglia
benessere scopriamone ora le connessioni
e addentriamoci un po' più a fondo In
questo mondo che riguarda tutti ma
proprio tutti noi Nessuno escluso una
delle tante domande che mi fece
all'inizio della mia ricerca fu È
importante che i luoghi nei quali
trascorriamo più tempo ci aiutino a
provare in modo forte e continuativo
emozioni belle e continuative belle come
quella della meraviglia la risposta fu
assolutamente affermativa e arrivai a
questa risposta quando cominciai a
mettere la testa ad approfondire il
campo dell'epigenetica
è un parolone difficile ma Lo
affronteremo in maniera assolutamente
leggera che cosa ci dice in estrema
sintesi l'epigenetica ci dice che l'uomo
e l'ambiente sono profondamente e
costantemente connessi l'uomo influenza
costantemente il suo ambiente e
l'ambiente influenza costantemente la
vita il benessere e la salute dell'uomo
afferma inoltre che l'ambiente ha
addirittura la capacità di modificare la
modalità con cui i nostri geni si
esprimono In definitiva sembra avere un
effetto addirittura sulla nostra
biologia Ma andiamo un po' più in
profondità nella visione epigenetica
l'ambiente assume un significato più
ampio rispetto a quello a cui potremmo
Istintivamente pensare associandolo ad
esempio al tema dell'ecologia piuttosto
che agli ambienti cioè i luoghi nei
quali le viviamo che cosa intendo Vi
propongo una suddivisione drastica del
concetto di ambiente suddividendolo in
due livelli vi anticipo che la visione
dell'ambiente secondo la base
epigenetica è qualcosa che si lega molto
al nostro stile di vita Innanzitutto
Abbiamo quello che possiamo definire
ambiente esterno l'ambiente esterno può
essere costituito ad esempio dalle
persone con cui viviamo o lavoriamo ma
anche dal cibo che mangiamo dall'acqua
che beviamo l'aria che respiriamo ma
anche ciò che leggiamo che guardiamo in
tv e ovviamente i luoghi in cui
abitiamo e poi vi è un altro mondo
quello dell'ambiente interno l'ambiente
interno è quello che di noi gli altri
vedono
pochissimo sono i nostri pensieri le
nostre emozioni Le nostre credenze a
livello subconscio le nostre
sensazioni tutto ciò che appare nascosto
alle persone nel nostro ambiente esterno
Cosa succede se trasportiamo questi due
livelli dell'ambiente
nell'abitare possiamo ipotizzare che
tutto ciò in cui siamo immersi ad
esempio della nostra casa quindi aredi
colori materiali eccetera possono avere
un impatto sul nostro ambiente interno e
viceversa il nostro ambiente interno
quindi le nostre emozioni sensazioni
pensieri eccetera possa avere un impatto
sul nostro ambiente esterno quindi
potenzial mente anche sulle altre
persone e tutto ciò che ci
circonda dovremmo tutti quindi fare del
nostro meglio per creare ambienti
interni ed esterni il più positivi
possibile voi Mi direte come farlo
ovviamente ci sono tantissimi modi
tantissime strategie ma ce n'è una che
vi consiglio cominciamo a prestare più
attenzione a come ci sentiamo nei luoghi
dove trascorriamo il nostro tempo
pensiamo all'effetto che ci fa entrare
in uno stadio delirante durante un
concerto immediatamente ci sintonizziamo
sulla carica energetica che altre
migliaia di persone stanno provando
effetto diverso potremmo averlo ad
esempio entrando in un nostro luogo del
cuore un luogo dove abbiamo provato
delle esperienze meravigliose oppure
anche un luogo naturale perché no un
luogo sacro pensiamo alle Sette Chiese
qui a Bologna o San Luca Capaci
immediatamente di infonderci pace e
tranquillità Ma la domanda è da dove
arrivano queste sensazioni che cosa le
genera solo le caratteristiche visibili
estetiche dei luoghi oppure magari anche
le persone che quei luoghi li vivono e
perché no le esperienze che noi stessi
abbiamo vissuto in quei luoghi e se
fosse un mix di tutti questi fattori E
se questo mix condizione anche il valore
che ciascuno di noi associa ad un luogo
pensateci
bene quando cominciai a pormi queste
domande capì che mi stavo immergendo in
un mondo molto molto ampio e che
richiedeva tutta me stessa avevo In
definitiva ridefinito la mia Mission a
livello professionale immagazzinando
tutte queste domande cominciando a fare
delle prime ipotesi avevo solo un'ultima
cosa prima di fare lo shift definito
comunicarlo ai miei genitori Voi direte
cosa c'è di strano nel comunicare un
cambio di lavoro ai propri genitori
niente di strano È solo che
condividevamo da diversi anni un bello
studio di architettura mio papà
architetto mia mamma interior designer
io architetto davamo tutti per scontato
che avrei proseguito nel tempo lo studio
fondato da loro con tanta passione
energia e amore negli anni 60 quindi la
mia
non era così semplice nel senso che
temevo di farli soffrire Tuttavia presi
il coraggio e diedi la notizia e come
potete immaginare fu un durissimo colpo
per loro era la fine del 2013
quando ufficialmente cambiai la mia
professione una professione che poi si è
rivelata una vera e propria missione una
missione che mi ha fatto capire quanto
stia veramente diventando urgente
integrare e promuovere un'autentica e
sottolineo autentica cultura
dell'emozione
nell'abitare lo dobbiamo a noi stessi e
lo dobbiamo alle persone a cui vogliamo
più bene vi starete chiedendo che cosa
possiamo fare nel nostro piccolo in
concreto ho tre cose da suggerirvi la
prima cosa cominciamo Possiamo
cominciare a cambiare l'ordine delle
domande da farci prima di trasformare i
nostri ambienti cioè prima di chiederci
che cosa mi piace che cosa mi serve o
che stile voglio dare al mio ambiente
perché non chiederci che emozioni che
sensazioni voglio provare o meglio
ancora che bisogni desidero che il mio
luogo mi aiuti a
soddisfare vedete generalmente quando
Trasformiamo i nostri ambienti Ad
esempio la nostra casa soddisfiamo dei
bisogni che possiamo definire classici
il bisogno di sicurezza di privacy di
comfort di bellezza di funzionalità di
costo eccetera ma in realtà Ognuno di
noi ha un altro ordine di bisogni molto
molto più profondi assolutamente
soggettivi il bisogno di leggerezza di
pace di energia di autostima di
amore Ognuno di noi ha un'infinità di
bisogni più profondi e comprendere che i
luoghi hanno la potenzialità
di aiutarci a
raggiungere quegli scopi diventa un
passo
fondamentale seconda cosa che possiamo
fare ricordarci e vi prego ricordatevelo
davvero che tutto ciò che ci circonda ha
il potenziale di modificare il nostro
ambiente interno e dunque la nostra
biologia e terza cosa di
conseguenza vi consiglio di scegliere
tutto ciò che dovrà essere portato nei
vri vostri luoghi affinché questi
oggetti materiali colori possano
soddisfare quei bisogni più profondi che
abbiamo visto
ora in questo meccanismo ovviamente
scompaiono dogmi Mode e Cliché crolla un
po' tutto e compare Però un concetto
magico il concetto della
risonanza cos'è la
risonanza è quella sensazione
meravigliosa che proviamo quando
abbracciamo qualcuno a cui vogliamo
profondamente bene tutti noi sappiamo
quanto sia potente Un abbraccio
sincero possiamo anche descriverla come
quel fenomeno assolutamente naturale che
accresce in modo istantaneo il nostro
benessere in virtù di una relazione
positiva con qualcos'altro e questo
qualcos'altro è qui la cosa interessante
possono essere ovviamente le persone ma
anche i luoghi gli oggetti le case i
paesaggi le opere d'arte qualsiasi cosa
la risonanza noi la proviamo
quotidianamente con un'infinità di cose
e la risonanza applicata all'abitare va
creata con metodo e consapevolezza
perché è qualcosa che è molto più
profondo di un semplice mi piace o Wow o
che bello che cosa
intendo come non è detto che tutte le
persone che definiamo belle ci facciano
provare emozioni positive così non è
automatico che tutti i luoghi che
definiamo belli abbiano lo stesso
effetto su di noi e non è neanche
scontato che tutto ciò con cui siamo in
risonanza e che ci piace esteticamente
sia ciò che serve a noi per raggiungere
gli obiettivi più profondi i bisogni più
profondi che servono a noi per
raggiungere uno stato di benessere
totale facciamo un esempio applicato ai
colori è conoscenza diffusa che il verde
e il blu siano i colori più Giusti Se
vogliamo raggiungere uno stato di calma
quiete e
tranquillità ma non è sempre detto che
tutti i verdi e i blu con cui siamo in
risonanza che ci piacciono e che sono
perfetti per il nostro ambiente ad
esempio la nostra camera da letto siano
quelli più giusti per noi per
raggiungere quello scopo questo perché i
colori ma come in realtà tutto ma
proprio tutto ciò che risiede nel nostro
ambiente esterno ha la potenzialità di
richiamare nostre esperienze passate
condizionamenti
esterni di cui potremmo non essere
consapevoli e che a lungo andare
potrebbero portarci a risultati molto
diversi da quelli a cui stiamo tendendo
E quindi cosa possiamo fare di nuovo
ascoltiamo il nostro corpo il nostro
corpo è una meravigliosa antenna
naturale comprende tutto tutti noi
abbiamo la capacità di sentire se il
luogo nel quale viviamo lavoriamo che
frequentiamo è positivo o non positivo
per noi e agire di conseguenza di fatto
Qual è la prima cosa istintiva che ci
viene da fare quando Vediamo che una
pianta è sofferente cambiare
l'ambiente Perché non farlo anche per
noi vedete io Credo profondamente che i
luoghi abbiano da donarci molto di più
di ciò che abbiamo sempre creduto e che
la loro capacità di diventare
naturalmente rigeneranti terapeuci
nutrienti dipenda in primis dalla nostra
disponibilità a riconoscere i nostri
bisogni più profondi e di utilizzare i
luoghi in modo creativo per soddisfarli
è come se diventassimo progettisti
consapevoli della nostra vita attraverso
i nostri
luoghi
ovviamente servono anche dei
professionisti pronti ad accompagnare le
persone in questo emozionante avventura
abitativa e fortunatamente ce ne sono
già molti che proprio per istinto o per
scelta integrano nella propria visione e
professione questo tipo di approccio ho
Tuttavia scelto di dare vita a una
squadra di professionisti appassionati
nell'applicazione di queste teorie nella
trasformazione e progettazione dei
luoghi E vi assicuro la cosa
interessante è che chi si AV a questo
mondo ha compreso che ciò che vediamo
dei nostri luoghi come in realtà di noi
stessi È solo una minima parte di ciò
che
esiste solo una minima
parte se qualcuno mi chiedesse in questo
momento che cosa amo di più fare
oggi risponderei quello che sto facendo
in questo istante qui con voi accendere
la curiosità ovvero accendere lampadine
perché ogni lampadina accesa ossia ogni
luogo che sia una casa un giardino un
ospedale una scuola un albergo che verrà
progettato realizzato e vissuto con
quest'ottica più consapevole porterà
benefici concreti non solo alle persone
che quel luogo lo vivranno ma molte
altre
persone questo per un semplice
semplicissimo motivo Perché siamo tutti
profondamente connessi
in fondo di cosa abbiamo parlato questa
sera abbiamo parlato di amore amore per
noi stessi per le persone a cui vogliamo
bene e amore per i nostri
luoghi abbiamo parlato di come anche la
più incasinata stanza di un adolescente
abbia in sé il potere di farci stare
bene tutto parte da noi in quest'ottica
e tutto ci ritorna perché prima noi
plasmiamo i nostri luoghi e poi essi
plasmano noi
[Applauso]
grazie